hey how are you I'm good man how can I
help
what's up watching YouTube channel
speech did you post an Instagram I had a
deep doubt in my instinct like how I
need to quit my job and do the thing
which I love which is okay trading meat
stocks trading stocks okay yeah all
these days I've been spending a lot of
time post my nine-to-five jobs literally
I am from India so it is not
nine-to-five is more than that I need to
continue the job or I need to take a
route to have a full-time trader in the
stocks so I'm not sure currently I I
couldn't take in addition on that since
the if I have a file the fear of failure
is like it's as huge in play it plays a
huge role in my decision making decision
out of fear is never the place to live
when you are making decision out of a
scared place you always lose it
paralyzes you and you end up doing
nothing which is the biggest mistake of
all the biggest mistake of all don't let
that happen now what do you do is the
next step I think of a couple things I
think one I try to get a job in the
industry if you need to have a job I'm
not the guy who's like burn the boats
and go all in on this thing that you
haven't figured out if you want to do it
or not I like to test the reason to have
a job is to learn yes to make money to
support yourself but you're not gonna
get rich from your job it's to learn so
I'm trying to get a job I would try to
get a job in the industry where I'm
trading socks I'm learning I'm making
connections I'm making some money but
most importantly I'm building my
education you're basically getting paid
to get an education but if you having to
pay so get a job in the industry - I'm
also starting on the side I'm starting
part-time starting in the evenings off
hours I'm looking for exchanges that are
open while you are at home in the
morning I don't know what the time
difference is India to North America but
you know first thing in the morning
either either first thing in the morning
or late at night when you're getting up
in them or at night like the u.s.
exchange is open or if you trade the
Europeans or you can trade the
Australian stocks like there's always
options for you to start your hustle on
the side to learn while also having a
job in the industry so it starts with
the foundation point of when you make a
decision out of fear you lose when you
are afraid of something and that's what
prevents you from moving forward you
lose if you fear failure you lose
because failure will happen if you wait
until you're amazing to start as
something you should have started it way
sooner so failure is coming embrace the
failure expect to fail it's awesome and
you're not gonna fail forever you're
gonna fail you're gonna try again you're
gonna fail and try it again you're gonna
figure it out and then even then once
you've figured it out you'll need to
fail more new things because you don't
want just the same thing forever and
ever and ever and ever and ever changing
the perception changing your mindset
around failure and what it means to you
is super important and then to get a job
in the industry we're gonna learn and
three start in your hustle right now
trading on the markets that you can go
and learn from before your job starts or
after your work ends and go so feel
momentum I hope that helps also if you
want to know what I think and what other
successful entrepreneurs think about
building confidence check out my new to
54 confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days for free I will send
you a 30 second to five-minute video in
the morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below if you want to be
more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that passion
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's something serene if you liked
this video check out the one I made on
the 7 things to do before quitting your
job the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there and here
are my seven things that you should look
at before you take that leap full-time